foreign
everybody it's September 29 2022. I'm
Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report and
obviously uh it's a little bit of a
rough day here in Florida as you guys
know I'm I'm in Miami uh but Southwest
Florida Miami of course is southeast
Florida Southwest Florida has been
absolutely ravaged I mean I don't even
know the word to say uh by Hurricane Ian
which basically came in and hit landfall
just a tick under a category five
hurricane but it wasn't just the
strength of the hurricane this thing was
absolutely massive massive massive it
then went kind of up the coast and now
it's more Inland uh where now it's a
tropical storm but it has done just
extraordinary absolutely devastating uh
damage to uh to my new my new home and a
place I'm very proud to call home and a
place that I I truly love and I think is
a beacon of freedom for not only the
United States but for the entire world
so we're going to talk a little bit
about out the hurricane I'm going to
show you some videos we're going to talk
about proper leadership during a
hurricane and competency and all of that
stuff but I know a bunch of you have
been emailing and asking we're totally
fine here in Miami I've got a generator
we do have a leak in the roof it's been
raining for a couple days it's easing up
right now actually the weather the
weather is pretty decent uh right now
but I'll talk a little bit more about
what what I know and some personal stuff
related to Southwest Florida which is an
area the Naples Fort Myers Sanibel
captive area an area that I've been
going through my entire life that I
absolutely absolutely love but there
were just crazy videos I'm not going to
belabor it too much for you guys because
I'm sure you've seen it but there were
just unbelievably uh insane videos of of
houses being pulled away and boats
piling up on top of each other 15 to 17
foot storm surge really just uh crazy
stuff but I want to focus a little bit
since we do politics around here
um you know these natural disasters have
happen all the time we have hurricanes
and fires and
also in earthquakes and all sorts of
things that happen all the time and some
of it is uh it's up to God or whatever
you want to call it it's up to the
universe to the Earth whatever it is and
humans can do a certain amount to
mitigate the damage and for days now
Florida's been doing everything possible
and uh unfortunately because Iran
understand this we have a really
competent uh group of people here really
from the top to the guys that'll be
fixing the polls and draining the water
and all of the stuff but this is gonna
this is gonna take weeks and months and
in some cases years we'll get to that in
just a sec we're gonna throw the ad
first or we're gonna go right into uh
all right so let's uh let me show you a
quick video this is Governor DeSantis uh
talking about
um
hurricane Ian and what's going on here
the impacts of this storm are are
historic and the Damage that was done uh
has been historic and this is just off
initial assessments there's going to be
a lot more assessing that goes on uh in
the days ahead but I think we've never
seen a flood event like this we've never
seen storm surge of this magnitude and
it hit an area where there's a lot of
people and a lot of those low-lying
areas and it's going to end up doing
extensive damage to a lot of people's
homes
okay so DeSantis has been doing press
conference after press conference and he
has called in every resource he did
speak to President Biden it took by it
in a little while to get back to him but
it sounds like federal funds will be
available I mean how about we stop
giving billions of dollars to Ukraine
and maybe put them into what's going on
here in Florida that would be something
imagine spending our own dollars on
ourselves wouldn't that be something uh
anyway despite the competency obviously
there's just a crazy amount of damage so
here's here's a quick compilation of
some of the stuff this is southwest
Florida mostly what we're going to show
you is the the Fort Myers Naples Sanibel
area
foreign
thank you
and so I know all of these areas quite
well uh Connor we're going to put up
that last one though in in the box right
there I know this corner very well I've
been going to Sanibel Island my entire
life uh this is the corner of Cassie
Bell and uh Periwinkle which is the main
road there in uh in Sanibel Jerry's Food
Market is to the right they've got
parrots out there where if a woman walks
by they go pretty lady and that the
store there you're seeing to the left I
think is called Mango Bay I have bought
a million t-shirts and uh hoodies and
sunscreen there I bought this hat there
one of my many Sanibel hats I got about
10 Sanibel hats downstairs I I just
can't imagine you know that was a little
Mom and Pop Shop run by a little old
lady who's probably in her late 80s or
early 90s you know like a true Florida
woman with that Florida tan we'll see
what happens the island might so my
grandma bought a place down there in
something around 1972 before there was
even a bridge to the island by the way
the bridge the Sanibel Causeway has been
completely destroyed so there's no way
on or off the island right now but my
parents eventually when my grandma pass
took over the place we have no idea if
the place is standing obviously property
damage is what it is it's more important
that the people there are okay I do have
two friends that live on the island
full-time who I haven't been able to get
in touch with I mean it's really just
it's just extraordinary uh disaster and
I just want to be very clear about one
thing as as a new Floridian and someone
that is so appreciative of everything
that Florida has afforded me I'm going
to do everything I POS we can in the
next however long it is to help these
people rebuild and I'll do fundraisers
for free and I'll donate money obviously
and I've already talked to a million of
their you know sort of the Florida
influencer crew and we're all willing to
do absolutely anything uh that we can do
so I'm hoping that my parents place is
still uh standing and uh and we will see
it is it is very weird but of course as
you know and now we can get into a
little more of the Regular Show you know
everything that happens in the world
whether a lightning strikes or there's
an earthquake or you know a volcano
blows up or whatever it is it always
gets politicized and of course uh that
is what's happening here and it's it's a
damn shame because you know DeSantis has
made such a clear uh and and straight
line to taking care of the State uh but
you know the usual suspects thereafter
him and of course they're also making
this all about climate change so we're
going to get to that in just a sec let
me talk to you guys about relief band
for a moment uh you know where Joe Biden
and the Democrats disastrous policy
making you nauseous I'm a little
nauseous this morning did you know that
one out of three Americans regularly
regularly suffer from nausea well
there's a solution you've got to check
out relief band relief band is the
number one FDA cleared anti-nausea
wristband that's been clinically proven
to quickly relieve and effectively
prevent nausea and vomit vomiting
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraines hangovers morning sickness
chemotherapy and much more whether you
need everyday nausea and relief or just
an occasional cure for nausea their
patented technology makes feeling sick a
thing of the past forget the days of
nausea pills that make you groggy and
exhausted it's like the name says relief
band is legitimately a band that you
wear on your wrist to give you relief
from nausea and you can change the
intensity depending on how you're
feeling to make it stronger or weaker I
can tell you firsthand that relief band
actually works I always look at my phone
when I'm in an Uber or Lyft I bring my
relief band with me know how no matter
how long the car ride is just for peace
of mind so if you want a band that
actually works to relieve your nausea
check out relief band we've got an
exclusive offer just for Reuben report
listeners go to reliefband.com use promo
code Reuben you'll save 20 off plus free
shipping that's reliefband.com and use
promo code Reuben for twenty percent off
plus free shipping okay so look
there's an absolute humanitarian
disaster ravaging the state right now
every American should care about it but
you can feel it you can just feel the
way the media just they would love for
this to be a really horrific disaster
with hundreds if not thousands that I
really mean that they would love it
because they would get them to pin
something on DeSantis it's just how it
is it's just what politics has become
it's it's just a sad reality right but
it's not just that it's also that they
want to use a natural disaster to
further whatever their political goals
are whether it's destroying this anthis
or telling us that everything is because
of climate change here is uh CNN's Chief
wizard a man who was just demoted from
his evening prime time slot to the
morning so if you don't do a good job
and nobody likes it and nobody's
watching on CNN they take you from the
evening they put you on in the morning
and here he is explaining that this is
obviously because of climate change
can you tell us what this is and what
effect climate change has on this
phenomenon
we can come back and talk about climate
change at a later time I want to focus
on the here and now we think the rapid
intensification is probably almost done
uh so listen I just I'm just trying to
get that you said you want to talk about
climate change but what what effect does
climate change have on this phenomenon
that that is happening now because it
seems these storms are intensifying
that's the question I don't think you
can link climate change to any one event
on the whole on the cumulative climate
change may be making storms worse but to
link it to any one event
I would caution against them okay well
listen I grew up there and these storms
are intensifying something is causing
them to intensify oh Guys Don Lemon grew
up in the area so you know storms
possibly are worse than what he
remembers when he was a kid so this is
worth talking about on CNN I mean what
an abject clown these people
he does not deserve that microphone nor
the chair that he sits in there is no
evidence of it and the climatologist who
he was talking to uh was very clear
about it he said we should caution about
that he said climate change may they
have no idea you know what there are
horrific storms all the time there are
massive earthquakes all the time we CA
just because you want it to be something
Don Lemon you you want it to be because
of climate change because that will
usher in every other political thing
that you want right they just want it so
bad but think how stupid like profoundly
stupid you have to be to say something
like that on network television well
when I was a kid there were so it's got
to be climate change I mean it's it's
just extraordinary but it continues on
CNN here is former Sports Anchor Bill
Weir who apparently is not a Sports
Anchor anymore he does weather stuff and
yeah climate change
uh Ian is coming Ian's here John we just
felt a market increase in wind speeds
within the last 10 minutes or so I'm
just in front of the memorial for
Hurricane Charlie which in 2004
devastated this town and sent a wake-up
call to this community about the threats
of living on the coast in a rapidly
warming Planet uh as a result of that
storm they were the First Community in
Florida to put in a climate adaptation
plan a sea level Coastal resiliency plan
that they're you know have been working
on for years now and this will be the
test
but this is exactly what
climate Sciences have been warning about
for a long time and now we get to see
how close John
yeah just made up nonsense rapidly
warming climate rapidly warming Planet
this is what climate scientists have
been warming yes some of them have been
warning about it and some of them are
saying it's not happening and some of
them are saying it's cyclical and in the
70s they used to tell us about a cooling
Earth I'm not even saying that climate
change is not happening I'm not even
saying that man has not produced some of
the elements that cause some of it I'm
actually not saying any of that at all
what I am saying is these people use
they have no idea that is a former
Sports Anchor standing out there telling
you uh that if he was so afraid if he
was so afraid of it would he be there
would Barack Obama have his 30-acre
estate on the water in Martha's Vineyard
would John Kerry have all the things
that he has on all the water areas it's
just these people are just liars and
baboons and they will do anything for
politics and of course the best thing
you can do for politics is destroy your
opponents and sort of wish death on
people here's Joy Behar from The View
this is the quote from Governor DeSantis
about climate change quote I am not in
the pews of the Church of the global
warming leftists this is what he thinks
about climate change and now his state
is getting hit with one of the worst
hurricanes perhaps
Joy you have no idea if this is anything
to do with climate change you have just
simply no idea what DeSantis is saying
is just because the media and the left
say that this is all climate change and
all of these things and AOC says we have
12 years to live and all of this stuff
it doesn't mean any of it's true it
simply does not mean any of it's true
and there's there's also a certain a
certain Joy right she Joy she's Joy
Behar she's actually quite joyless but
when people are being hurt in a place
that she doesn't like then there's a
certain Joy there like you see he's
saying this while his state gets hit
really really it's just so incredibly
dumb anyway here is more of DeSantis
last night and let's contrast that with
let's contrast Joy they are with what it
sounds like to be a real leader uh and a
little bit of where is Biden
when a natural disaster like this
strikes a state it is it is common it's
I I think it's always the case that the
state receives federal aid given how
politicized things are at the moment are
you confident you're going to get the
federal support Florida needs
so I actually spoke with the president
and he said he wants to be helpful so we
did submit a request for reimbursement
for the next 60 days at 100 percent uh
that's uh significant uh support but
it's a significant storm so we haven't
heard back from it but I'm actually
cautiously optimistic that we do I mean
as you say tucker we live in a very
politicized time but you know when
people are fighting for their lives when
their whole livelihood is at stake when
they've lost everything if you can't put
politics aside for that uh then you're
just not going to be able to so I'll
work with anybody who wants to help the
people of Southwest Florida and
throughout our state amen
yeah
that's what a leader does that's what a
leader is supposed to say it's not all
about politics and I am going to for a
moment uh give Joe Biden the benefit of
the doubt for just one moment and I
understand he's not in charge and all
that stuff I'm going to give whoever's
pulling the strings the benefit of the
doubt for the moment and assume that
they are going to do the right thing
here and make sure that Florida gets all
of those federal funds uh and that
they're not going to somehow punish
Florida because they don't like that
Florida's become red or they don't like
Governor to say this there's simply no
doubt that the administration at some
level would love this anthis to take a
hit here right it's just how politics is
it's just reality but I'm going to hope
that they do the right thing and and
again whatever I can do over the next
months and years I mean some of this
stuff is going to take years I'm
absolutely going to do it because I am
full of gratitude for the state the
people that live here for Florida man
for the Gators and the iguanas and the
frogs and everything else and uh there's
there's work to do uh all right we got a
Reuben report locals q a for you and
it's actually I'll shift my tone a
little bit when we get there uh in just
a second uh because it's we've got a
wide variety of questions that I quickly
glance through so I'm looking forward to
that uh let me talk to you about real
estate agents I trust real quick you
guys know that buying or selling a home
is already one of the most stressful
things you can do and it can be 10 times
worse if you're not working with the
right agent generally speaking our homes
are our biggest investment which is a
ton of responsibility and you need an
agent who takes that seriously which is
why I recommend real estate agents I
trust they work with only the best
agents in every Market they do their
homework talking to every agent before
inviting them to join their Network and
here's a big one they only work with
full-time Pros no part-time or
inexperienced agents their team makes
the introduction and then follows you
through the buying or selling process to
make sure that you're satisfied the
agents they work with have long track
records they're the best sellers in
their field they're part of this
audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
just go over to
realestateagentsitrust.com today and
provide them with some basic info their
team will contact you to make an
introduction to a preferred agent in
your town as an and as I always say then
you move to Florida and live happily
ever after we're a little banged up at
the moment but it still has my uh stamp
of approval okay so let's get to the
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a
the questions are all over the place
today which is sort of what I wanted in
light of uh what's going on here summer
says did you used to despise
conservatives or just disagree with them
you know it's interesting because look I
was a progressive I was a lefty I was a
Bernie Sanders supporter there's
evidence of it online it's all hard to
believe but it's true all of it
um I don't think I had the hatred like
the pure hatred in my heart that many of
the progressives did and even my
colleagues when I was on The Young Turks
like people were always screaming and
really angry and mean and you can go
back I don't recommend you do but you
can go back and watch videos of me there
and I was always a little more calm I
was always a little more measured I
don't think I went out of my way all the
time to call everyone a bigot and a
racist and a homophobe I have no doubt
that I did it sometimes I have no doubt
that I regret some of the things that I
said about people that I'm sure I
consider friends now or at least that I
consider decent politicians like Rand
Paul and Ted Cruz Etc et cetera but I
don't think I had that like endless
hatred and and so much of what
progressives have it's almost all they
have right now they have that in
censoring you right there's like an
incredible amount of hatred there's an
incredible amount of we want to control
you there's an incredible amount of we
want to censor you and there's not a lot
of thoughtful let's talk this thing out
I mean where are these people we I again
I say this all the time like show me
someone who is legit I'm not talking
about a like a YouTuber troll someone
who is legit who is in a in government
or works for an interesting non-profit
uh or is it is a honest to goodness
pundit uh who wants to have an honest
conversation and defend the Biden
Administration defend anything happening
with the Democrats defend wokeness and
have that conversation of course I will
have that conversation but what was
interesting was
years ago when I first started doing the
show back in you know 2015-16 when I was
really waking up to all of this stuff
all I was still a lefty and I kept
saying hey we we liberals have to defend
liberalism all that you guys get it when
I started talking to people on the right
suddenly all these people on the right
were like Dave you know I disagree with
you on everything but thanks for giving
us a place to talk and then all I got
was endless hate on the left so that is
the asymmetry and that asymmetry
actually I just taped an interview with
Dennis Prager yesterday about uh his new
book
um and we talk about it because if you
view Politics as everything if it is
your religious and your cultural uh
prism through which you view the world
you will be endlessly miserable and you
will do all sorts of awful things but if
you have another way of looking at the
world and politics is just a piece of
that you might be a little bit better I
sense that it's something like that
lobrian says since Rumble went public
will cfvi stock convert to Rum yes it's
it's happened as of basically last week
and that's why I rang the bell with the
rumble people so cfei was a SPAC it's a
special purpose acquisition company it's
a whole long story it basically helps
you as a private company go public
faster it was really spax were like the
thing for the last two years to help
companies get public and then there were
a whole bunch of failures the market
really cooled Rumble looks like it is
going to be the SPAC of the year that's
sort of all I can say on that
specifically but yeah rum is now being
traded on NASDAQ and I'm very very proud
of this company
um you know I'm a consultant for the
company obviously I own a portion of the
company I'm not here to give anyone any
kind of financial advice or stock tips
or anything like that but I believe in
this company and
um you know the locals team and I
created locals and we merged with Rumble
the locals team is awesome we are
building this stuff together there's
there's a lot of cool things happening
right now so yes r-u-m is trading on
NASDAQ right now Alan says hello Dave
how did you and your family really fair
the storm yep as I said we fortunately
got spared here it's been raining pretty
non-stop for the last like 72 hours
until until this morning where some sun
is shining we do have a leak in the roof
in the house so I've got a bucket
downstairs we're trying to get some
roofers here but obviously uh it's a
little a little tough at the moment so
we've got someone coming on Wednesday
today's Thursday man I got six more days
of a leak in my roof not much I can do
um although if anyone if any of you are
roofers in the south Florida area and
you want to get in touch with me and
swing by that would be just fine
um you know we've had some tree damage
and and that kind of stuff we've got a
window leak and whatever it's really
been fine here and to contrast that with
what's happening
um in Southwest Florida as I said
Sanibel Captiva I mean I can't tell you
Sanibel is my truly my favorite place on
earth like my favorite place I I've
joked with my family over the years that
if I was ever because people always ask
me if I would ever go into politics and
it's like the one thing that I honestly
think I could have done maybe at some
point or maybe could do would be that I
could be mayor of Sanibel just this like
tiny Island and I would do everything I
could to to know the people there and
and make it I just love that island and
it's going to take all you know the
bridge is destroyed like absolutely
destroyed it's it's nuts it's really
nuts
um cat says what if any interest you
think Elon Musk has in Rumble so some of
you may have seen this yesterday was it
yesterday or the day before actually
it's been it's two days ago thanks
um it's been a weird 24 hours
um
Elon Musk actually started tweeting back
and forth with Dan bongino and Chris
pavlovsky who's the CEO of Rumble and
there is some stuff to discuss and I
hope that there will be a sit down
whether or not I'm involved is
irrelevant
um but I think that he could really Elon
could really help us you know either
through starlink or just being involved
I tweeted at him I said man forget
Twitter forget Twitter it's damaged it's
damaged goods man you're buying a broken
product and you know it if you're if
you're going to buy it whether he wants
to at this point is unclear to me
um but there is better options and and
Rumble I would say rumble locals is the
option for a free and open internet it
is it free speech has gone public it's
as simple as that and I hope that Elon
will get involved and the funny thing is
it's like the company doesn't need money
it just went public there's a lot of
money there it's not even about money
it's about it's about brain power and
Ethos and and spirit and all of those
things that I think he could bring to
the table even if he just wanted to
advise something like that Chuck says
you always say that you do not have to
be a conservative a republican a
Christian Etc you just cannot be a
Democrat or believe in this woke garbage
it is a message that proves that you
would rather different People Unite
against the common foe than push people
away what would you say to those who
would rather push someone away or other
or other them in the same way the left
does instead of realizing we're on the
same side look this is this is an
incredibly tough one because we all
have complex relationships whether it's
with family members friends you know
politics because it has become so
all-encompassing you throw in the
craziness of covid where people who knew
nothing about politics or nothing about
civil liberties were suddenly being
demanding that you be injected to things
and people were not invited to their
children's weddings or grandchildren's
birthday parties like the the
extraordinary craziness of the last
couple years like so much stuff has been
Unearthed and in some ways I think
there's there's an opportunity there
there's there's goodness there because
as as shitty
the best word I can come up with as
shitty as it was all of it it like it
really made people think about what they
want what are you doing on this Earth
what do you really believe what type of
state do you want to live in what
government do you believe in are you
doing everything you can uh in in the
limited time that you have on this
Mortal coil
um but what do you do about the people
who just endlessly want to push away I
mean look at some point
I always believe in putting the hand out
and I'm I'm pretty decent at it I think
sometimes I'm probably not so decent at
it we all have different relationships
that are very complex all of those
things but you can only put your hand
out so many times and have it smacked
away so I think sometimes you have to
kind of let something go to have it come
back that would be my overriding point
here you know I believe that right now
there's this incredible opportunity for
all of these people that don't really
make sense to be allies right it's why I
talk about Bill Maher so often it's why
when this podcast drops next week I
think you're going to find it really
interesting it's like you've got these
these liberals who are realizing that
that in some Essence liberalism is
destroying liberalism it's weird leftism
is destroying liberalism you've got
these people with sort of Libertarians
who just want government out of
absolutely everything then you've got
sort of traditional conservatives social
conservatives religious conservatives
now talking with Libertarians these
Libertarians who maybe they don't care
about same-sex marriage because they
believe that your freedom is the highest
thing then you have conservatives who
maybe come from religious perspective
and maybe they're not thrilled
with same-sex marriage I'm just using
this one as an example for their own
religious view but they're realizing hey
we do want to live in the same country
with these people and respect individual
rights and make sure that it's not the
government that tells you how to live
you have a chance to figure out how you
want to live which is actually directly
connected to that incredible speech that
the Italian the incoming Italian Prime
Minister gave yesterday about the
individual versus the collective I think
that's what I've been trying to
illuminate on this show for for a couple
years now and and in the books that I've
written so there's an opportunity for
all of these people to unite defeat the
woke thing and then we're gonna have to
hash out some stuff and maybe it will
not work really maybe it will not work
that this new alliance will will fully
fit together but I think there's a
chance and I think it's the only chance
to get out of this madness so but at the
same time if you're just always putting
your hand out to someone and they're
always shooting you down and they're
they're not giving you anything like
you're not I don't think you're on this
planet to be abused so at some point you
got to cut your losses Sarah says Dave
did you ever date women
we're mixing it up today
um I did I I sent a lot of women to
mental institutions I met a couple women
in mental institutions actually
um I did I really really tried
um because nobody thought that I was gay
I I was very you know I was closeted
really into my mid to late 20s
um
so like because I would go as if I went
to a bar usually girls wouldn't think I
was gay so they were hitting on me like
I I really try it and actually if any
woman that I ever slept with or dated or
anything is watching right now I
apologize I really do I I personally
apologize to a couple of girls after
like I really was trying and then at
some point it just kind of didn't work
if you know what I mean like I really
really tried and we're getting too
personal today so it's early we haven't
had lunch
um but I really I tried and it's like
you know it is what it is and and that's
why you know being in the closet is such
a it's such an awful thing you know
there's only room for one in there and
there are some people that it's obvious
that they can't be in the closet right
they come out and they're immediately
Like There's No Business Like Show
Business like there's some of those and
then there's just other people and
um it in some ways it's harder for other
people I used to kind of Envy these like
over-the-top gay people because I was
like oh it must be kind of so easy for
you it's so obvious
um and I never felt that way so I felt
like sort of doubly a freak and I
struggled because of it and drugs and
and all sorts of stuff but I obviously
I'm on the other side of that and I and
I'm living a good life right now and I'm
a new father with another kid that could
come literally any minute at this point
oh which reminds me if uh if I have a
couple days off the show we'll obviously
post something somewhere but like
surrogate 2 could pop at any moment so
you know I might disappear for a little
bit we'll see
um but yes I dated women and uh you know
nobody's perfect what can I tell you
they call them a gold star gay you guys
know about that if if you've never slept
with a woman they say you're a gold star
gay
not what can I tell you Uh Kevin says
how was your first month juggling your
schedule and being a new dad you know
it's been
it's been pretty good I actually my
mornings have really changed so I I
really love my mornings now so I'm in an
early riser about 7 A.M or so we're
trying to get Justin to sleep till about
eight o'clock obviously there's feedings
at night and you know you want to get
these kids to stretch he's on the big
side he's like 85th percentile so
because he's big he's stretching in his
sleep longer and longer so even though
he's only about six weeks old he's
almost stretching to like five hours at
night over the last couple days which is
really great but I start my mornings I I
get him I prop him up on the he's you
know he's wrapped in his swaddle this is
like a you haven't seen this thing it's
like a it's like a straight jacket for
children and they wrap them up and I put
them in his swaddle and I prop them up
with the blankets and pillows and things
and then I have my coffee and I sit
there and I I talk to him it's just in
the last couple days that he's now
responding like where there's some
Smiles that seem like they're like
genuine like I'm looking at you Smiles
not just kind of like looking at the
universe kind of thing
um so it's been you know my day
I'm doing the show and show related
things and working on things basically
from you know eight to to five or so but
I'm seeing I work at home so I get to
see them throughout the day uh and then
at night we get a little bit of time and
and all that stuff it's been it's been
good nice and uh I'm blessed I suppose
uh talway says what are your thoughts on
the collapse of the Nordstrom one and
two pipelines and how do you think this
will affect the balance of power in
Europe as winter starts to set in so
first off Phoenix can we make sure we do
like a real recap on this nordstream
thing next week because we couldn't
really get to it this week maybe I'll do
a little bit tomorrow but basically the
nordstream uh pipeline not the Nordstrom
pipeline which is what uh Karen
Jean-Pierre called it that's a very
expensive shopping store that you can go
to
um
a shopping store there you go
um it blew up and this is uh now unclear
like who blew it up how Germany's going
to get energy it's a whole freaking
thing people are saying Russia might
have sabotaged their own pipeline uh
there is this video circulating from
like a year ago where Biden says that
you know the Nord stream 2 basically
will not be functional don't worry about
that and it's like did we just blow up
the Nordstrom Pipeline and if we did
like how is that not an act of War it's
really really messy
um we'll get more into it let me get a
little more info for you and compile
some stuff and we'll discuss it a little
bit more uh Xavier says what do you
think the left will do if Trump wins in
24 they have built him up to be such an
evil super villain that no response will
be off limits imagine the delicious
tantrum that will be thrown by Joy Reed
Joy Behar Don Lemon Etc why are they all
named Joy everyone named Joy is so
joyless it's incredible look this is a
huge problem this is a huge problem I
think this is a huge problem whether
it's Trump or DeSantis and in some way
You could argue it's a huge problem
whether it's Trump DeSantis or any other
Republican this was the this was the
thing watch my videos from six years ago
where I kept saying guys we got to stop
calling everybody Nazis because just
because they disagree with us on taxes
or Borders or whatever it might be this
is when I was a lefty it does not mean
that they are Nazis they are not foot
soldiers in the German Army in World War
II but this is what the left has created
this has now permeated up the entire
political Echelon of the left there are
no moderate Democrats left and if there
are they're so cowed
and coward that there's such cowards
that they they do not fight the more
radical opponents so the Democrat party
has been decimated and what you've been
left with is now also a generation of
woke children who are genderless and
think that racists are coming to get
them and all this stuff this is a huge
toxic disaster and I have simply no
doubt that especially if Trump was to
win I don't know that the machine would
let him win but even DeSantis and I
think you could argue any Republican I
really think so that they will unleash
violence on the streets again I mean
think about it we had all the what
happened to Black lives matter what
happened to that thing when they were
ransacking two years or you know Summer
of Love And basically a year of ransack
in all these cities they stopped doing
it when Trump wasn't president anymore
they are connected to the Democrat
machine it is obvious antifa where are
they why aren't they still burning down
Connor have you called any of your old
friends in Seattle are they still there
the whole place it's like where are all
these people they are the foot soldiers
of the Democrats they work through ngos
and non-profits and and they know when
to turn the violence on and off and I
suspect that if a republican was to win
that there would be it would be endless
Mass violence but that is not a reason
for Republicans not to win we need
Republicans to win otherwise we just
continue going
down that route and it ain't good uh
schmoo says Dave I would love to know
what you wrote on that napkin on Gutfeld
so we played a portion of it as the cold
opened yesterday if you didn't see we
were doing a segment about Rashida Talib
from the squad and she is a communist
and really deeply anti-American Jew
hater like she's just like a disgusting
creature and uh and and she just hates
America she really just fundamentally
hates America so there was a clip about
her that they were showing on Gutfeld
and you know they give you a rundown
before the show so I'm able to compile a
couple thoughts so I I said a whole
bunch of stuff about her and then I
wrote on a napkin what I really thought
about her and I handed it to Greg
suffice to say
it was not very nice and as I said on
gutfeld's program if Greg had read it on
air I would have never been allowed back
on Fox and I'm pretty sure if I was to
read it here or tell you what I said
we'd be demonetized and maybe get a
strike on the channel but let's just say
you could probably
let's just say it was two words and you
could probably figure it out uh
ratafield says so what was it like to
have your first experience away from
Justin did you do a lot of video calls
God knows the first time is the roughest
and coming home is the best so you know
I was away I was in LA and New York had
about five six days and yeah David and I
facetimed and I said hi and there were
plenty of pictures and uh you know in a
way it was sort of nice to get away
because I do like traveling and I was
traveling for the right reasons too
right doing Bill Maher and going to
rumble and all this stuff and I got to
see some old friends so like that was
that was nice
um but I'm sure
it'll get easier over time because I was
obviously thinking about them a lot and
it's like I didn't want his for the
first smile as I said he's smiling right
now I didn't want the first smile I
don't think he's talking just yet but as
as more of those Milestones come you
know he stands up for the first time he
walks for the first time all that stuff
it's like you want to be around there
for some of that uh Larry says I look
forward to the talk with Bill Maher if
you'd like to tease what was the
highlight of your conversation with him
so first off uh just confirm if I'm
wrong on this for the audio podcast
we'll come out this Sunday for
subscribers only for Bill Maher's
subscribers is that right this Sunday
on Apple for Bill Maher subscribers then
one week later the full thing will come
out Audio Only and they'll be releasing
video clips throughout the week so I
wish I could tease more now talk about
it more now uh but as you heard me say
yesterday we had a it was the longest
podcast he ever did we really like we
churned through the stuff we didn't just
do politics for two hours we danced in
and out we talk about movies we love we
talked about struggling as stand-ups we
talked about philosophy we we told
personal stories he asked me a lot about
sex which I I really didn't love like it
was just like a lot and it was
everything and and it it I will say this
it did what I hoped it was going to do
the day before I left when I was ending
the show and I was saying what what do I
want to come of it what I want to come
of it is hey let's see if there's some
mutual respect here uh let's see if this
is the beginning of something not like
oh I had to take you out or you got to
take me out that was simply not the
purpose but I think as the conversation
went and it was getting stronger we both
could feel it and maybe it was the
tequila maybe it was the weed but not
really we both I think sense that as
this conversation went longer and we and
we went in and we danced into some of
the politics stuff that there was a
mutual respect
um
that was being birthed right within that
and it was all happening on camera so
it's it's really really good I think
you're gonna dig it so October 2nd on
the through the Apple paywall Audio Only
it'll be out on his channel October 9th
the full video uh will be on uh YouTube
and I would encourage you all because I
know you guys are curious about the
thing like really watch the full thing I
know they're going to bring out Clips as
well but I think if you watch the full
thing you'll see like a really nice Arc
like the first few minutes like we
really had to feel things out like you
know I'm walking into this guy's house
he for all he knows I'm coming to get
him and I sat down and it was like is he
coming to get me we had to like we have
to like do some work but but then it
became very easy and good and he's
invited me back to his place to play
ball with Woody Harrelson pretty cool so
I don't know that I'm ever going back to
LA but we'll see uh Ann says just
curious how your family especially your
parents feel about your rise to internet
and TV fame
um
I would say for the most part pretty
good I know my parents are very proud of
me and proud that I became a success and
you know they were there for all the
lean years right there were a lot of
lean years doing stand-up and struggling
and standing on street corners and
handing out tickets and having no money
and going into debt and just you know
nothing I had a buddy who worked for a
Food Distribution Company who would just
literally deliver me tuna for like two
years I just ate tuna out of giant
industrial sized cans probably gonna die
of mercury poisoning one day
um so they they were there for all that
so to see it on the other side I think
they're very proud about the work that
I've put into this and that I've built
these companies and done all this stuff
we definitely don't align politically
fully I've definitely sort of let's say
evolved or I've shifted let's say a
little bit more than them or I see
things a little bit differently than
them so we still get into it on some of
that stuff but as I always tell my
parents it simply doesn't matter if we
disagree on everything politically and I
really mean that it's like they're my
parents I'm their son so it just doesn't
matter matter whether we agree that
abortion shouldn't exist or should be at
15 weeks or anything else but that's
also to get back to one of the earlier
questions about why you have to have
like a philosophy Beyond politics
otherwise you'll end up hating everyone
around you you know if everything you
believe is through politics you're going
to find a difference that you have
politically with your parents with your
siblings with your spouse and if if
politics is like the sum totality of the
way you view the world you're going to
start applying those thoughts to all of
those people around you and really being
angry at all of those people and I
really do my best not to uh to do that
my family for the most part is pretty
good about having political discussions
it's definitely gotten harder since
covet I'm sure you guys feel that too
like my family used to be able to all
sit around a table we could talk about
foreign policy we could talk about
abortion I write about this and don't
burn this book we were really great
about that extended family aunts and
uncles every holiday it was like 30
people at a table everyone's screaming
fighting doing all this stuff dessert
got served we put it down and it was
like we were good to go kovid made that
more difficult for my family I have no
doubt that covet made it more difficult
for for almost everyone's family for you
watching this right now
um but anyway to directly answer your
question I think I think they're pretty
proud and they're probably watching
right now so there you go uh Paula says
I'm curious to know if traveling felt
differently for these for you this time
with having a baby at home if so did
that surprise you we sort of got to that
one already yeah it did well I just
thought about him right like you know
usually I think about David or something
but like now I'm thinking about another
person and next week there'll be another
person here and uh and that's also
what's kind of been nice
um about Parenthood in a way it's like
you know so much what I do I do a show
called the Reuben report everywhere I go
people say hi to me people are nice to
me for the most part but like there's a
lot of stuff in my life that's about me
and that's kind of weird
um to some extent it's really great it's
a validation of doing what you think you
should do in the world and hopefully
having a little talent and refining it
and all of those things and making the
right business decisions and whatever
but you know most of the places that I
go to and I think anyone that's a public
person to some extent you find this it's
like it's kind of always about you
that's not necessarily the best thing
for your ego or for your just like
psychological makeup all the time so the
fact that now there is this other human
in this house and it's really all about
him I'm very happy about that that's why
in the mornings when I sit there with
him and I have my coffee and I'm just
playing with them it's like I'm not
thinking about politics I'm certainly
not thinking about Twitter
um
but I guess like above us in that moment
is well I also got to save the world now
not just for me not just for David but
for this guy so let's do it Chad says
assuming the house and the Senate
flipped to majority conservative what do
you believe the top three priorities
should be well first off they I would
let's just do one basically they Must
Destroy Everything woke that is in the
government period every single piece of
equity that has been put into every Bill
the idea that if you get vaccinated it
should have something to do with your
skin color or that if we had a natural
disaster it should have anything or any
of the genders of all of that it must
all be eliminated we need a czar of
anti-wokeness we need someone to go in
and go let's find every place that
Equity instead of equality has been put
into our government and whether that and
we have to probably fire also sorts of
heads of departments we should probably
I'll do a couple more we should probably
cut budgets how about we cut every
freaking federal budget by 20 percent
right off the top every single one guess
what shit's still going to work okay the
Train's still going to show up on time
or not
whether it does or not it's irrelevant
you know what I mean like how about we
cut budgets how about we put money back
into the people and back into the
people's wallets we get rid of the woke
stuff and then we start to
govern somewhat competently how about we
hire some people that are supposed to be
hired so look if the if the Republicans
take back the house and the Senate
obviously Biden is still president and
the Democrats still have the presidency
the executive branch but it's like how
about instead of Staffing People based
on the color of their skin and who they
sleep with we start Staffing with
functional people and really we like we
just all kind of stand up straight with
our shoulders back and be like man we
got to the precipice of giving away this
country we got to to the to the end of
the road with this woke Collective
nonsense and and now let's let's all be
adults again and let's fix this thing
because it's either we fix it or we just
slide we just slide
speaking of fixing it I'm going to be
spending a lot of time trying to fix
things here in Florida and if any of you
watching right now if there's anything
you think I can do to help whether it's
interviewing someone or doing a
fundraiser which of course I'll do for
free or showing up somewhere or whatever
it might be please do let us know the
best way to get me is that
reubenreport.locals.com and parts one
and two I think of my interviews really
interesting one a little off the beaten
path from maybe what we normally do on a
domestic side with the political
director to Hungarian prime minister
Victor Orban his name is balash Orban
super interesting you know Hungary is
going through an interesting thing right
now because they are really trying to
protect their borders they're trying to
protect their culture they're trying to
defend individual rights they're trying
to figure out how to get through the
mess that now we're seeing here in our
country and we had a really really nice
talk Parts one and two up right now the
full thing is up at
reubenemport.locals.com and we don't
have a cold close for you today because
of the Florida thing I didn't want to do
anything kind of silly or nonsensical
anyway if you're here in the great free
state of Florida I I wish you well hope
you're doing okay and if you're anywhere
else I still wish you well and hope
you're doing okay and we will be back at
it tomorrow just because of our short
week this week we're not going to do a
panel I'll be doing a Regular Show we'll
hit that nordstream thing and a couple
other things
um
nice day goodbye